gegeben ist das lokal gerne gesehen ist
es ist ganz schwierig dass man so ein
satz steht herzlich und solange die
leute ich habe heute wieder luca an
meiner seite und heute ist der große tag
bekommen leute wir reagieren auf den
fokus beitrag der dich letzten endes
beruf gemacht hat der dieses ganze mihm
entstehen lassen hat mit der du bist
komplett in der beschreibung verlinkt
unten mit der miete können entwickler
kanal hat der check in auf jeden fall ab
und ich habe richtig bock drauf wir
starten würde ich sagen direkt rein und
übrigens wir vorher einfach nicht ich
habe schon interview gedreht sucht das
einfach beim kanal dann sie durch das
verleihen
der 13 jährige luca aus haddorf am herz
trägt seit dem kleinkindalter ewig
machen dass jedes zehnte anhaftet adhs
aber ganz ehrlich das war auch nicht
korrekt vor dem dk was hat er gemacht
guck mal der video bald beginnenden du
kassierst man erstmal ganz endinger ganz
ehrlich wenn die folge schon so anfängt
da wird ja auch ausrasten egal der
bankrat anblicks vor einem jahr also was
soll das denn ja ok aber die habe ich
angesprochen das cover verkommen wir
sagen für all dieses interview noch
nicht gesehen habt euch wieder voran
weil sie es auch nicht gemacht habt
genau adhs drucker ist jetzt tatsächlich
zutreffend also du hast auch immer noch
die adhs richtig manchmal ist der titel
oder dieser mihm name den manche leute
bekommen ja auch komplett falsch so aber
in dem fall ist dass das krankheitsbild
ja und als ich jünger war war es damals
noch schlimmer man über die täter bei
den reden der szene ja das ist so soll
ja leute ohne witz wie geil ist das dass
das jetzt dass das möglich ist lokal
hätten dank an dich haben hier ihm vor
zehn jahren das ist zehn jahre alt
hast du gesagt jetzt du sitzt nicht mehr
in deiner heutigen aktuellen form wir
können aber zusammen auf der bmw gaal
ist das ist haben ich bin das krank aber
du sitzt hier auf der burg
ja in der szene habe ich auf meinem
bruder gesehen dass das hörst du auch in
dem moment wo ich mich nach hinten bist
mein bruder der die residenz pass mal
auf was ich jetzt noch mal die rache für
den für den mazda aber sowas ist die
beste heimische reiter ferrari ist und
heute ja was heißt für mich eine
krankheit die mit ablenkung sehr viel zu
tun hat für dich gekürzt
das war ein paket mit meinem ganzen
sache hat die ganze zeit darauf gefreut
deswegen waren die reporter in dem
moment scheißegal sind es kam auch im
moment wurde ja gerade luca meinte auch
im internet wird ihr merkt die machen
die ganze quälerei damit ihr alles
versteht was wir hier sagen du hast auch
so dass bisher in dir drin so dass du
auch eine show jetzt gerne ist ist das
was was zwingt mit adhs kommt oder oder
hättest du das auch der handel das würde
ich so nicht sagen
ich habe jetzt von vielen ist dann habe
ich sage ich jetzt mal gehört dass die
auch sage ich jetzt mal nicht unbedingt
gerne show machen wollen aber ich war
halt wirklich schon immer entertainen
drauf also dass das war schon so sage
ich jetzt mal mein ziel hat den leuten
immer irgendwie spaß zu bringen und in
der reportage kamera an los gehts alter
dann jetzt ich mache jetzt slapstick ich
bin hier dass das unterhaltungselemente
auch wie daher ist beispielsweise zu
sehen ist abgehen und das hat sich dann
mal
ja abgestochen zwiebel geäußert beispiel
ich mich nicht geschnitten habe ich
wollt schreibt grippekrank heftig dort
was ich meine nicht geschnitten nicht
verletzen mein bruder hat es auch in dem
moment gecheckt könnte wenn es weiter
gut besucht
ja ja der russe hatte straub denn so
erkennt dich schon lang genug aber krass
deine mutter hat auch gerade dann ist ja
ist ja der mutter najah eine sache
angesprochen darauf eingehen also es ist
nicht ganz leicht ist sich mit adhs inso
soziale zur sozialen situation angepasst
oder angemessen verhalten richtig nett
und dadurch erschweren sich auch soziale
kontakte
es ist halt einfach sag ich mal so also
ich nehme mein umfeld einfach in einem
sehr sehr gesteigert
faktor also wenn ich in dem raum bin mit
zu vielen leuten nicht nehmen ich kann
mich nicht auf eine sache konzentrieren
ich nehme alle sachen weiter es ist alle
alles unwichtig genau alles kommt auf
einmal ich bin überall irgendwie
anwesend aber nie zu 100 prozent ja so
und das ist halt so da damit würde ich
eher sagen dass es halt zusammenhängt
dass du halt auch sage ich jetzt mal ich
nicht so wirklich auch auf personen
einlassen kannst oder ich sage ich jetzt
mal ein gespräch fokussieren kannst
erschwert leider vieles also viele viele
adhs und ads la haben tatsächlich
soziale bewegung schwierigkeiten okay
der stress zwischen den brüdern er ist
vom mittelgebirge ins alpenvorland
mitgereist und mittlerweile immer noch
man kennt man kennt das aber so
klassiker stress zwischen brüder und die
sah ja natürlich
kleine rohde so erfüllt jetzt einfach
auch die rolle der tod einfach das was
man auch ein stück weit von ihm erwartet
die mutter hat mir am telefon gesagt so
schlimm haben sie noch nie gehabt krass
weiß was mir denkt wenn ich jetzt so was
höre wie wie ist das denn für dich wenn
du wenn du sowas siehst weißt du dass es
erst mal gesehen hast das hört hört ja
niemand gerne über sich selbst
also näher ich kann zeit besteht ja ich
kann es absolut bestätigen weil ich
kenne auch niemanden in meinem umfeld
der sage ich jetzt mal so krass drauf
war wie ich also damals erhältst du mich
jetzt in der schulklasse erlebt wo ich
mich gemocht locker
also du wirst auch absolut ich mich da
gekommen niemand kam mit mir klar so das
war heisst das ding und auch was er
jetzt sagt das so einen schlimmen at
kearney diesem beruf muss man halt
erstmal gerecht werden
das sagt er zum nächsten moment und das
ist leider wirklich so gewesen ich kam
diesem ruf jedes mal gerecht lokalen
schnell und legt man beachte die
arbeitssicherheit hier unterstützt gut
ich sehe die chancen auch da ja
berufsgenossenschaft sagt ja ja
unfallversicherung sagt ja ja da kann
ich nichts machen wie viel schutz
möchten sie an ihren füßen stark
sparkassen 10 erreichen
diese wird diese plastik ratschen hier
den sonntagen die wärme in die wangen
statt
das sagt ja was kaputt machen können es
war vor allem hat das daher keinen druck
war du kannst hier mithelfen musste es
aber nicht und das ist sein auch so bei
ada ist deshalb sage ich jetzt mal wenn
von dir aus kein interesse kommt wenn du
das für dich selber nicht als logisch
wenn du denkst nicht war ängstlich und
weiten du denkst nicht sag ich jetzt mal
über den über den normalen horizont
hinaus
das ist das was in dieser situation die
er gerade was bringen und versucht diese
bedürfnisse zu befriedigen ja jetzt
einfach mal und in der schule wirst du
ja zwangs mäßig nur und nur dazu
gezwungen war also macht das macht das
genau besonders jetzt rein seht ihr das
jetzt rein und ich habe einfach den sinn
dahinter nicht gesehen vor allem wenn
wir jetzt von leuten hörst dass nachdem
der aus der schule raus bis zu einen
monat danach nur noch zehn prozent von
dem stoff verinnerlicht dass die hs im
doppelpack beim nächsten einsatz bekommt
betreuerin sowie die geballte ladung an
wer ist jetzt der typ mit dem ich hätte
wegs ist das war einer der auch mit
offenem gekommen ist er ist felix und
der hat auch sei jetzt mal
integrationsschwierigkeiten hier an der
schule ja der war ein auch sehr
provokant sehr
anders highlight war aber nicht der der
dich dann nein es ist nicht der den sie
den süßen im zweiten teil einmal ganz
kurz
es ist ein experiment was hier oben auf
einer alm in den schweizer bergen
passiert aber du hast etwas hier nicht
gewonnen weil sie entweder nicht ich
hatte einzelbereichen klarkam
ach so okay ich war genau da oben drüber
da oben drüber gaben einen dachboden
bereich du warst auf dem dachboden
allein also du kannst dir vorstellen der
abstand von da vom boden bis zur decke
ist die 1 meter 50 uhr kannte die später
noch wichtig wird ja gesagt und auch für
den 14 jahre alten luca krause ist es
ein neuer weg und ein steiniger auch für
seine umgebung
wie war das eigentlich mit den jungs
zusammen zu leben war das war das so ein
pulverfass weil das sind ja alle jungs
die dann mit dabei waren haben ja
irgendwo irgendwie begründet wieso
bisschen so eine integrations
schwierigkeit oder so kann man das so
nennen mag das nicht ganz das chaos
die ersten sechs wochen waren nicht an
frühstück zu den ersten sechs wochen war
nicht an irgendwie ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl zu denken jeder hat
so sein ding gemacht alle sind irgendwo
rum getanzt die schlimmsten waren nicht
und der etwas korpulentere pascal
hierbei wurden ausgegrenzt weil ich war
der psycho er war das dickerchen war
echt nur chaos
also du hast das zimmer am anfang
gesehen das ist das ist so so war das
leben da alles komplett und drüber ich
hatte gegen ende der einem übrigens über
300 über 300 striche finde ich finde
fake news ich finde dass nichts falsch
gemacht
was dies für gerechtfertigt
ja gut aber acht wochen war sie vitale
56 tage heißt durchschnittlich pro tag
so zwischen fünf bis sechs striche ja
wesentlich
wir werden keine probleme hatte und zwar
ist die auch mal wieder so lange das
wahrscheinlich zwei teile machen müssen
der zweite teil dann auch mit dem ein
meter fünfzig moment dass er in diesem
video auch noch drin ist auch teil muss
das wehr sondern auch viel zu lange also
ja spätestens in zwei tage geht weiter
lukas oder in der beschreibung verlinkt
findet ihr euch vorstellen könnt ihr
main kanal abonnieren sechs kanäle ab
und sagen